Hello, everybody!
I'm still eating, by the way.
I'm so... Sorry, dad's gonna be barking because he's in baby jail right now.
Because he knows I have lasagna.
By the way, I'm eating my lasagna.
All right, so, story time.
It's a very short story.
Remember how I ordered two lasagnas?
Well, I accidentally ordered three lasagnas.
I didn't want to post a picture because I was like a little embarrassed.
I was like, oh, maybe three is a little too many to show on my public Twitter.
So, I know there's not a lot of people watching Silent Hill because I'm like, oh, my god.
All right, there's a PA testing system.
Oh, my god.
Sorry, I didn't realize.
I don't know if they ended it because I suddenly heard a breathing from the PA.
So, apparently, there's PA testing.
I came home from dance lessons and then there's been a PA test system for the last 30 minutes.
It comes in randomly.
I don't know how long they've been testing this fucking PA system, but they always be like, I don't know what they're going to say.
So, I mute myself because I don't know what they're going to say.
I'm worried they're like, PA testing and blah blah blah.
I'm like, vlog, I don't need that.
So, every time I hear the ping, I just mute it because I was like, I don't know.
I was like, do I wait until the PA system is over and then do the stream?
But I don't know when it ends.
They've been doing this for like six times already.
Since I got back from dance lessons, I know I'm eating lasagna right after dance lessons.
Like, I'm filling up the carbs I lost from dancing.
Yeah, I'm so healthy.
So, yeah, I accidentally ordered three lasagnas instead of two.
I didn't say anything.
I didn't post a picture because I was a little embarrassed because I was like, okay, two was like, hee hee and then I realized if I show three lasagnas, people are going to be like, she has a problem.
So, that's when you're like, wait, I think that's a problem.
So, I started three because I actually double tapped on one of the lasagna.
I double tapped on one of them.
So, I didn't check the, you know, I was doing it on stream.
So, I wasn't, you know, I wouldn't, I wasn't really paying attention because I was doing it on stream.
So, I didn't realize I accidentally tapped twice on one of the other lasagnas.
So, not only did I had jalapeno, jalapeno poppers and mozzarella sticks, I had three lasagnas.
So, yes, I've been eating.
I've been trying to get rid of all the excess food.
You know, when I said I'm gonna become a joke field, I didn't realize that this extends off stream as well.
I didn't know how committed I was gonna be to the bit, but now I don't even think it's a bit anymore.
I think, I think it has seeped into real life.
It's gotten too, it's gotten too real.
Chat, Mondays, am I right, guys?
Oh, Mondays.
We'll have new emotes.
Um, we actually have five new emotes, but I haven't uploaded the other three yet, because we're gonna be doing the great calling.
We're gonna be eliminating some of our old emotes to fit in the new emotes.
So, we're gonna be doing that at the end of the stream.
So, um, this is your chance to vote on which emote we're gonna send off the island to fit in the three new emotes.
Um, because we reached the limit, like, it doesn't matter how many gifted memberships or how many new members join in, we've reached the YouTube limit when it comes to emotes.
So, because we reached the limit, we actually have to get rid of some old emotes to fit in, um, to fit in the new ones.
Um, and after that, we also have, uh, I think we also have five more emotes coming in as well.
So, we have to call, we have to purge again after.
There's gonna be two purges happening.
Not the second one, the second set won't be here soon.
Um, so, uh, we're gonna be purging the first set of emotes and then the second set, you have time to, you have time to love, you have time to spend your time with your loved one, with your loved emotes, uh, before it's their turn to get purged.
Um, it's not a Hunger Games scenario where, like, one of them's gonna survive.
Uh, they're all, they're gonna get purged.
So, uh, five, six, seven, eight emotes will be purged.
So, this is your time to spend time with the ones you love the most.
Uh, Fiction, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, I just got paid so I can continue our conversation for you to play Spec Ops The Line and the alternate way to play is a physical copy?
Wait, on, like, what console?
What console though?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You know, the one game I will actually buy a physical copy for is Minecraft, um, the Minecraft Telltale series.
I will buy a physical copy for that, like, because it can't be PC because, uh, I don't have a CD, I don't have a CD-ROM thing on my PC.
Um, I can't finish this lasagna.
Someone wanted me to give a lasagna review.
Which one was better?
The one with meatballs was surprisingly better.
Um, I actually liked the one with meatballs the most.
Um, it just had, I don't know, it was just better.
They both looked really different and the one with meatballs was the one with 2,000 reviews versus the 50 reviews one.
Um, I don't know.
I'm eating the one with the, I think also right now, I didn't try both.
I didn't try both because I was like, which one do I want to eat for, like, the day after, you know, which one do I want to eat post Doki field?
And then I tried both of them and I like the meatball version better.
Um, I didn't eat a little bit of the other one, the one with 50 reviews, and I was like, it's not, it's all right.
And then now I'm eating the one with 50 reviews right now.
And I don't know if it's because I, oh my god.
Still, they're testing the, oh my god, like, they're testing the fire alarm, but I'm like, I'll just die in the fire.
I'm like, why is it still going?
Doki, no!
I'm done, Doki.
I'm just like, please.
Why does it, it's been going on for like an hour now.
I'll go down with this shit.
Um, Arthas, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, I think you're taking this Garfield roleplay too far.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, we just got back from dance classes.
Um, it's a very intense dance I'm learning, um, for one of the songs.
And like, um, um, they were like, uh, they were like, oh, uh, the teacher was like, uh, this is a different teacher, by the way.
Because I have two different teachers for different songs, because like, I don't want to get like, my head like, explode and stuff.
So for this teacher, I didn't dox myself this time, so she doesn't know who I am.
This time, I didn't dox myself for this one.
Um, anyway, I was like, oh yeah, I have to do a concert.
And, um, she was like, oh yeah, um, like, um, because I told her like, I don't know how to dance.
Like, I was, she was like, okay, we're gonna, she went to my set teaching like, a total beginner.
And she was like, and then while we were learning to dance, she was like, are you sure you don't dance?
And I was like, no, I was like, because she's like, you're doing really, you're learning really fast.
Are you sure you don't, are you, you've never danced before, or you don't dance?
I was like, well, last year, I did dance lessons for a concert.
And it's so, so she was like, oh, okay, that makes sense.
Or maybe, but I still don't dance.
I was like, but I still don't dance though.
And so she was like, oh, oh, it's because you're like, you do like singing, right?
You, you're musically inclined.
So like, you understand the rhythm.
And I was like, well, I'm not a singer either.
Oh, my fucking God.
That one was a fast one.
Okay, so.
She was like, oh, okay.
Like, I was, I was like, no, I'm not singing either.
Like, my, the one I'm, I'm doing the concert with, like, she's the singer, dancer.
I'm just there.
And she's like, oh, okay.
Well, you're such a fast learner.
Like, oh, my gosh, you learn really fast for someone who doesn't dance.
And I was like, oh, thank you.
I really appreciate that.
But yeah, I indoxed myself to this teacher.
So like, we're safe.
She's not judging me with my lasagna.
She doesn't know about my lasagna.
Damn.
I've had my ego filled for a little bit.
Oh, I want to eat the cheese off of this.
All right, guys, I am stalling.
But I actually have a good excuse to stall though.
Like, I am, I am allowed to stall.
I didn't eat my food yet.
I am allowed to stall this time.
Okay, anyway, so we're gonna be playing.
Oh, wait, did they post this today?
Oh, shit.
Okay, give me.
Okay, apparently.
Okay, I am gonna post it today.
Okay, there's gonna be an announcement today about something.
But I'm waiting until they post it.
Um, I just received a discord message.
So like, maybe they'll post it while I'm streaming.
That'll be cool.
Anyway, Arthur, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Every time I hear that thing, I keep thinking your lasagna is done.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Well, I hope it gets posted today because I just freaking talked about it a little bit.
I'll be like, there's something coming up today.
Well, I'm not posting it.
Somebody else is posting it.
So I don't know if it's gonna.
I don't know.
They're like, maybe.
Okay, I'm done with my lasagna.
Well, I'm not done.
But it's a lot.
It's a lot of lasagna.
Anyway, so enough procrastinating, enough stalling.
We're about to play part 534 of Silent Hill 2.
I have no idea how many, how long we're gonna be on the silent.
I'm so sorry, God of War.
I didn't know it was gonna take that long.
I was looking at the original Silent Hill game and the original Silent Hill game was like, you know, 10 hours.
So I was like, oh, that's fine.
10 hours, that's fine.
And I looked at it, I looked at the remastered, and the remastered one is like, way longer, apparently.
It's way long.
It's like, you know, nobody, no, it's like longer.
So I was like, oh, fuck.
Okay, that, that's awkward.
Because the only reason why I decided not to go back to God of War was that, oh, maybe the Silent Hill one will be super quick.
And then we'll go back to God of War because I didn't want to do God of War.
And Wukong backed it back because it felt very similar.
So I was just like, oh, it's fine.
But it wasn't fine.
It's, it wasn't fine.
I'm pretty sure everybody else has finished Silent Hill 2 already.
And I'm still doing my, I'm still, I'm still there.
I'm...
We're still in it.
We're still there playing Silent Hill 2.
Also, I'm playing in the morning now because, like, we're getting to the nurses.
And I heard it gets a lot scarier when we're at the nurses part.
So I was like, yeah.
It's morning hours now.
We're doing the morning, we're doing the morning shift now.
All right.
Hello, nurse!
We're Silent Hill 2.
All right, there you go.
Let me boot up Silent Hill 2 now.
I didn't even boot up the game, guys.
I was not, I'm mentally not there anymore.
Oh my god, where the fuck did I put... All right, Silent Hill 2.
I have, like, the sound configured for it and everything, too.
All right.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Sorry, I just need to...
I'm just mentally getting ready.
D-Dragon, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Been replaying the OG because of your streams.
Did you know, Doki, that you wasted bullets against PyramidHead?
As you could have just waited the fight out and he would just walk out without a fight.
Oh, no, I know I did.
I was, like, the second try.
The first try, I was shooting him.
The second, the first try, I was shooting him and then you guys were yelling at me.
I was like, why?
And then after that, I was like, oh, the second try, I didn't shoot him.
I only shot him for, like, funsies because I felt like it.
I sort of forgot the controls, too.
It's been a while.
It has been quite a while.
So, I definitely forgot the controls.
Okay, and then...
Oh, yeah, you're still here.
Oh, fuck, I almost forgot Lady.
Hello, Lady.
Oh, my gosh, I actually forgot where I am.
Like, actually.
Okay, um, I'm gonna remember how to get anywhere.
Okay, all right, and then this is the dodge.
Okay, there we go.
All right, time to shoot some nurses.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, I remember now why I hated this game.
Okay, what did I unlock again?
I don't remember.
I don't remember what I unlocked.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Okay, not this, obviously.
All right, I'm okay.
Oh, my god.
Okay, I don't remember where to go.
Oh, the bathroom time.
Maybe it's bathroom time.
Surely, there's nothing bad in the bathroom.
There's never anything bad.
Guys, how do I heal again before I move on?
How do I- Oh, she doesn't come with me to the boy- men's bathroom?
So polite.
I think she thought that I was gonna use the bathroom.
All right, guys, how do I heal again before I go in and just cry?
Before I- I- oh, my god.
I hate you so much.
Before I- I'm feeling addicted with the 10 gifted ships that you take.
Okay, here we go.
No, okay.
Well, it's not this one.
It's clearly not this door.
I don't know which where to go.
Why are you looking at me like that?
Oh, why is everything so dark?
Where do I go?
Do I go here?
It's been a while.
Okay, um.
Oh, why is it circled?
Oh,
do I go there?
Is it here?
Guys, is it- oh, please.
Why did nobody play the electric build?
Oh, I just- Guys, where do I go?
Do I go here?
Where do I go here?
Where is it?
Guys!
Okay, do I have keys?
Guys, please, please, please, please.
I'll- I'll cry.
You don't want me to cry.
The elevator.
Okay.
Two.
Oh, and- oh, she's here.
Okay.
Okay, guys.
I know everybody has- I know everybody has finished this game and I'm still here, guys.
But, like, you're- you- even if I have one viewer left watching part 532 of Silent Hill 2, I'll still stream for that one viewer.
I'm doing for you, one viewer.
Even if we're still in the hospital at part 255, we're still gonna be here together.
We're still gonna be here in the hospital.
Oh, is this the nurse?
What's wrong?
It's gonna be 50 years and Doki will still be playing Silent Hill 2 and still be in that fucking hospital.
Is she okay?
Yeah, are you okay, ma'am?
From what?
We were- when did you drink?
Oh, earlier.
You had one- one cup.
Oh, I don't think you should tell her to sleep on that.
Bro.
Come- bro, I don't even- I think there's, like, bugs in that mattress.
There's bed bugs for sure.
No,
don't look at her.
She's- I know.
Don't look at her.
I know she's so sexy, but don't look at her.
Remember, James, you are a man of God.
Do not fall into temptation.
Don't look at this.
Oh, I shouldn't say that.
I know.
Don't look at her legs.
You guys can't see it, but don't look at her legs, James.
Stay strong, James.
Fort Mary.
Back off, wench.
The fuck?
Where was- where was the elevator?
Oh, right here.
Oh, God.
Guys, would you blame me if I don't- I just never finish the game.
It's just- we have part 15 and then never again.
We never came back.
We- Oh, yeah, it's November, James!
November, James, don't do it!
Don't- he's trying to make James- don't fall into those temptations.
You'll be stronger without her.
Wouldn't that be funny?
If just suddenly- if I just- if like- Actually, no.
If I just like come back to the game every like couple of weeks, it'll be like, all right, guys.
It's been two months.
Uh, welcome back to Solid Hill 2.
We're like- We're like every how- every October, we just- We stop the playthrough and then- And then on October, we come back.
We'll be like, all right, guys, we're back.
It's October.
You know what that means.
It's Solid Hill 2 again.
So annoying.
But I'll never do that to you guys.
I would never chat.
Now you're gonna think next week, will Doki come back to Solid Hill 2 next week?
Come and find out.
All right, nice.
We need our meds.
All right, guys, I'm gonna take- get cough drop real quick.
I'll be right back.
I need to get some cough drops because I'm coughing again.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
All right.
Here we go.
At least cough drops let me stall a little bit more.
Okay.
I guess- oh, I guess I have to go that way.
I guess we go the other way, I guess.
Oh my god.
All right, here we go.
For real this time.
For real.
Oh, hey, what's this?
Leave the rest to us.
Oh, this is nurses.
I like how they scratched up her face.
Because they're like the fucked up nurses.
They're still hot because, you know, James is a fucking degenerate, but...
Oh, here we go.
Do we headshot the nurses or shoot them in the knees?
Guys, what is it?
Oh my god, I see a nurse and I'm ending a playthrough.
I'm joking, I won't end the playthrough.
I just- I won't feel good about it.
Oh, there she is.
Thank god she's so slow.
He did that!
Oh, shit!
Just to be sure.
Did he come back alive?
Guys, did he?
Hello, nurse.
She's into that.
Wait, guys, did he- did he come back alive?
You have to say- I didn't think they would start running!
I was like, oh, of course.
Oh.
Does she come back alive?
Oh my god.
Oh, there's too many...
Too many areas.
Hello?
I don't want to waste bullets, please.
My bullets!
I don't want to waste my bullets!
I hear them!
That's the worst part!
Stop!
Wait, how do I crawl?
I don't remember how to crawl.
Oh, hello.
I never crawl.
Oh, there they are.
I'm just gonna get rid of him first.
Wow, fuck!
Oh!
Okay, that's bullshit.
Like, there's three.
There's three!
I- Okay, that's fine.
That's fucked up.
There was three of them.
Like, what do I do?
There were three.
All right, at least there's no nurse.
I don't know if I can stagger the nurses.
If I could stagger the nurses, it'd be better.
Can you stagger nurses?
Because I don't want to waste my bullets.
I don't have a lot.
Can you?
With the- with the knee shots?
But with regular pistol.
Hello?
What is the other nurses?
Oh...
Eat her drawings.
The fuck?
That's just a fucking- those are bullet holes.
Okay, okay, so if I can stagger them with pistols, that's good.
That's good.
Okay, so I don't have to waste, uh, I don't know- because I don't know if I can stagger nurses.
So like, that's good to know.
God, get the fuck off.
Look at that.
Three against- three against one?
That's illegal.
Whoa.
Okay, let's see.
Oh, the nurse's station.
All right, maybe there's stuff in here.
Oh, yeah, no, my heart is not doing- all right, guys.
I wonder what the password could be.
Hmm.
The code has been reset to what we agreed on during yesterday's meeting in the doctor's lounge.
Uh...
Like I said, I don't want anyone writing it down on little pieces of paper for me to find.
Be responsible, people.
Oh, wait a minute.
Oh, god damn it.
Surely one of you guys are- God, you guys are typing random- you guys are typing random numbers!
You guys are typing random numbers that make it look so believable.
It looks so believable.
It looks so believable, too.
Wait.
God damn it, one of you will crack.
I know it.
Guys, if you guys give me the correct code...
I will shout out your name.
You get- you get the exposure.
Oh, imagine- whoa, tab!
Exposure!
One of you will crack.
I- I know it.
I know one of you is gonna crack right now.
There's no way.
You're-
One of you- it only takes one.
It literally only takes one dragoon to fuck it all up for everybody.
It literally only takes one dragoon!
One dragoon!
God fucking damn it.
You'll crack.
I- I can feel- I can- One of you is gonna crack.
It's gonna happen.
I know it.
You think you're so strong, but I know it only takes one dragoon to fuck it up for everybody.
All I need is one.
All I need is one weak little guy.
To be like, oh my god, I want Doki to give me a shout out.
Oh my god.
I will acknowledge you.
I will acknowledge you as a person if you give me the correct code right now, you will get acknowledgement.
Right now.
Right here.
Oh.
It only takes one.
One back- backseaters, come on!
Oh, I- Backseaters, I know you really want to give me the code, backseater.
Are you really gonna go against your training to not backseat me?
I'm just a- A dumb VTuber who needs to be guided.
Also, woe is me.
I don't know what the numbers are.
I'm just so stupid.
Oh, I'm so stupid.
Skill issue.
That's a fine bias.
All right, we saved.
I'm pretty sure I'm making this a longer playthrough by- by just standing there waiting to get the code.
Wait, what?
Oh, I have to exchange something.
Oh, I have to give him watches?
You can't tell time, you're ahead.
Uh, what?
What?
Sudden outburst of aggression, visceral, and I- what did I miss?
Water has common, it used to.
Initial- what?
What do I do with this?
What do I do with this information?
All right, what's this?
Delusions persist.
Um, sensory delusions, insomnia, refuses food and water, force feeding, and hydration.
Bathing required, sleep medication, constant surveillance.
Oh, that sucks, bro.
Okay, and then this one.
Um, move to lower floor.
Intense and unrelenting anxiety, symptoms have intensified into full-blown paranoia.
Increase in medication, can't be left alone.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
All right.
Well, can't be left alone.
What do I do with him?
Wait, what do you mean by going far?
What does he mean by that?
What's he gonna do?
Oh, I don't like the sound of that.
He's gonna do something.
Oh, what is he gonna do?
What do you mean by that?
Okay, it's this way.
I don't believe you guys anymore.
You have lost your backseating privileges now!
Um, because of what you- because you guys are so stubborn, now I'll never let you backseat me again!
Unless...
you could, you know.
All I'm saying...
All I'm saying, you don't have to let that happen.
There's one way to fix that.
You know that hurts you more than it hurts me.
You know that, guys.
Okay.
Let's see.
There is...
I guess we go this way first, right?
Yeah.
Okay.
No, it- no, it doesn't.
Don't say that.
Alright, any crazy people in here?
Hello?
What's this?
Oh.
Fucking hell, a riddle?
Okay.
The following interview was conducted with blank in response to incident 071.
I remember lying in the water...
Empty, and then I felt him.
Felt him stare.
He was close.
Very close.
I had to get out.
Had to get away.
But he followed.
He kept staring.
So I made him stop.
Now I'm empty again.
Can we go back to the pool?
Oh, wait, did he kill somebody?
He must have killed somebody.
All right, I don't know what to do with that information, but okay.
I don't know what to do with that, but okay.
All right.
Count the words?
Is this a haiku?
Haiku?
Oh.
Hello?
Oh, there has to be somebody here.
No way.
You're so predictable.
You're so fucking predictable.
You thought I was gonna go right side, but I saw this item first, which had nothing in it.
Which...
There was nothing in here, but I did see that item.
I did see it.
That's all that matters.
So fucking predictable.
You're just crying in the shower, don't you?
What?
You get that hit?
I got the shot off first!
Oh, well.
Good thing there's this medication I was looking at.
That's so bullshit.
I literally got... that should have given me one free hit right there.
What the fuck?
I mean, he's just gonna be down here.
Like, what?
Is he gonna bite my ankle?
Bro, get up the fucking floor, you idiot!
You're biting my fucking ankles?
Like, what are you gonna do down there?
Okay, these guys are so pathetic, not gonna lie.
Like, these guys specifically.
I shot first exactly!
I literally shot first!
Okay, we got a shortcut here.
All right, love tap.
All right, guys, we're back here!
One last chance, dragons!
One last chance!
Hey, how you guys make these so believable?
I'm struggling!
I knew it!
I knew you'd crack!
I fucking... I knew I'm gonna show you to the world!
I knew you guys!
I knew you'd crack!
You fucking idiots, I knew it!
I fucking knew it!
It takes one dragon to fuck it up for the rest of you guys!
It only takes one!
Anyway, let's actually explore the other areas.
Shame!
I'm fine, I'm a traitor.
It only takes one dragon to fuck it up for everybody else.
Whoa.
That scared the shit out of me!
I was like, where did that come from?
I thought that was in my game!
I was like, what was that?
You set it up for him to get turned off by the others, did you?
Thank you for the super chat!
Oh my god, that thing actually fucking freaked me out.
I thought it was like part of the game and I was like, what did I do?
But what did I do?
Did I fuck up?
What was that?
That shit actually scared me, holy fuck.
I was not expecting that.
Oh.
I told you guys.
One person.
I knew you guys were weak.
I knew dragoons can't be strong together.
I knew you guys won't be strong.
It only takes one.
Are you fucking-
We're doubting!
How many times do you need to test the fucking fire alarm?!
How many?
How many times?
How?
Oh my god!
You just tested it!
What do you mean you had to test again?
What the fuck?
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god, she swings so fucking...
Oh, okay.
Maybe I should just do headshots.
I feel like- I feel like she- Yeah, I'm just gonna do headshots.
She takes way too much for melee.
Like three headshots is just better.
Three headshots.
I'm living in my own silent hill.
I'm actually- In my silent hill, they do fire alarms.
They do fire alarm testing.
24 times a day.
That's my personal hell.
How did they know?
How the fuck did they know?
The alarm means the other world is coming.
Run!
Thank you for the super shout out, a good user.
Thank you.
All right.
Oh nice, more ammo.
Thank fucking god.
I'm just gonna headshot the nurses.
Like it's just not worth it in general.
To like shoot them in the knees because headshot they die faster.
Okay.
We'll never figure out how to get when the puzzle for how we actually end up getting the code.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Uh...
We go to the front first.
Anything over there?
No?
Okay.
It's here.
Okay, there's loot here.
Oh, more shotgun for a gun I don't have.
That's cool.
What's this?
Oh, this has to be like from the previous games, right?
It has to be it.
Oh my god, I swear to god if the alarm- if the fucking alarm goes off one more time, I swear to fucking god.
I'm back to Silent Hill.
I feel so immersed right now being trapped here.
Okay.
Truly is so immersive.
Oh, hello?
Hello?
Okay, there's a teddy bear.
Whose teddy is this?
Whose bear is this?
Oh?
Somebody stashed something in you?
What do you have inside you, Mr. Bear?
What is it?
A fucking needle?
I could literally make this myself.
Like...
I'm pretty sure there's like needles everywhere around the floor.
Do I- do I really need this needle from a fucking bear?
Like I could just look at the- what the- oh I thought- Oh, there it is!
Nice.
Never using that gun.
Only using that gun in a boss fight and never again.
Okay, press two.
Whatever.
I don't need- I don't need to use the shotgun.
Guys.
Shotgun.
Oh my god.
I only have that much ammo.
All right, never fucking using that for sure.
That's a waste of- that's a waste of ammo.
Okay.
Off we go.
How did you get back here?
Go to my left?
Okay, no.
Whoa!
There we go.
I was like, what the fuck?
How did you run so fa- oh wait, I'm lost.
She- she disoriented me.
Okay.
Oh, nurse's lounge.
Which way should I go?
Uh, maybe I should go this way first.
I think she planted John, so we turned on each other.
He wasn't even ready.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, is there anybody here?
Fucking hell.
I'm like so- My anxiety is so high right now.
Oh.
Oh my god.
John.
John!
If I yell out John's name, he'll get less scared.
I'm fucking- I hate- I hate it here.
I hate- I hate- I- It's so- Stop!
Like, I don't understand!
What are they testing?
What are they even testing at this point?
Like, it works!
It has work in the past hour!
It's worked the past hour!
What is there not to work?
This is abuse.
I'll talk to the fire department after this.
What the fuck?
I hear something.
Oh shit, that's not- Okay.
I just wanted her to get a bit closer.
I- the true horror is to get stopped by your PA system.
Thank you for the super- Oh!
Like, oh my god!
They added something new this time!
Now it goes BRING instead!
They added something new to the mix!
Oh my god, they mixed it up!
What a mix-up!
What a- what a fucking mix-up!
Now it goes BRING!
Oh my fucking shit.
Like...
Oh my fucking god.
Get me out of my personal silent hill.
That mix-up is insane.
I was- that actually freaked me out.
The worst part is like, they stopped and then they went back to it?
Like...
I don't understand.
They just- they stopped the- the testing and then suddenly they just were like, oh fuck you, I guess.
Oh my god.
Okay, L1.
Where's L1?
Which is the L1 key?
There's L3 and L2.
Oh, there's L1.
Okay, we gotta go L1, I guess.
Okay, it's this way.
Okay.
All right.
The fucking mix-up was real.
That actually freaked me out because I didn't expect the fucking RING!
There's a nurse here, I can feel it.
There's no way they give this room to me for free.
There's no way.
That's impossible.
Not that this game isn't- oh, they did?
That's crazy.
They gave me this room for free?
There's no way.
They actually fell for me here?
My god, that's insane.
No, I don't have to fight my way to here?
Oh my god, guys.
There is hope.
Hello?
What?
I don't- what?
Okay.
What?
What do I do with this?
I'm so scared.
Oh, I'm actually so scared right now.
Um, I'm gonna freak out.
I'm gonna actually freak out.
What do I do?
What do I do with this fucking cart?
Is there a thing I have to push it to?
Oh, it's here!
Okay.
Oh my god, I swear to god, I swear it's like- Testing, whoa, testing, fire alarm, fire alarm.
I swear to god.
Oh, I fucking- I swear to god, I'm gonna- oh my god, I'm gonna go downstairs and I'm gonna be like, shut the fuck up.
Oh, I'm gonna cure it.
All right.
I'm here now.
Oh, nice.
What am I supposed to do with that information?
Let me just reload my gun just in case.
Just in case.
Just in case I don't feel safe.
Oh, the nurse has to be here.
That's where I heard the radio.
Here?
Oh, I don't like this.
It's so quiet.
Are you here?
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
I'm, I'm okay.
I'm okay, guys.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I'm okay.
Okay, I'm still okay.
I'm still okay.
I guess I'm still okay.
I guess.
Down I go.
Whee.
All right, John.
Hello, crawling down deep holes.
Yeah, and possibly it's suffocating in there.
Seems so safe.
James only has good ideas.
That's right.
And that's why he stopped taking his meds.
Because his good ideas start running out.
If you take, if you stop taking your meds, then you'll...
Then you'll have, always have good ideas, guys.
Guys, disclaimer, please don't stop taking your meds.
You don't want to become just like James.
Guys, you don't, you don't want to be like him, guys.
Where am I?
Where is this place?
I am in... oh, I'm back here?
The fuck did I get here?
Oh, wait, how do I get back?
There's so many questions.
Why won't they help me?
Why do they keep me in here with him?
Wait, is that the little girl?
Are those notes from her?
Oh, oh, it's the typewriter!
Hey, that's Resident Evil.
Wait a minute, that's Resident Evil thing!
Unless Silent Hill has it too.
This is my first Silent Hill game.
What's this?
Where's this?
It's a marked bracelet.
Oh, it's a collectible.
Whoa, whoa.
Are the rats part of my Silent Hill 2?
Can you imagine?
The rats are part of my Silent Hill.
They're not even real rats.
They're not even...
Oh my God.
Oh my God, that's definitely not a rat.
That's definitely not a rat.
Well, at least we know.
Oh, it's one of the marked bracelets.
Oh, yeah, it's one of the bracelets!
Oh, fucking hell.
Okay, I'm okay.
Guys, no, this is not a good surprise.
Guys, I like happy surprises.
That was just like trauma.
That's just... it's just trauma, guys.
It's not... that's not a happy little surprise.
Do I just go... why?
Unlocked?
I guess I could just go...
Doctor's Lounge.
Can I go to the doctor?
I don't think I can.
Let's go back to the second floor.
Let's unlock that area.
It's a happy little accident, I guess.
God, I hate this game.
It's a good game, but God, it's... oh my God, this game freaks me out.
It's just too good.
It's just too good, guys.
Is that pressing?
The elevator coming down, why is it still taking 50 years?
I don't understand.
Okay, we got one of the bracelets.
We got one of the bracelets.
Hm.
Okay, you guys want to know which one I prefer?
I definitely prefer Resident Evil more because...
because I... I have a gun and the guns actually do something.
Are you fucking serious?
You got back up?
Bro.
I think she likes it when I shoot her in the head.
It's just understandable, like it's her head.
There you go.
I mean, like I get it.
It's your head, like you need it to do things, but like you're blocking the way.
It's literally self-defense at that point.
It's literally self-defense.
I'm just trying to defend myself.
Okay, we got one of them.
Oh, fuck, okay.
Let me go this way.
Oh my god, go here.
Wait, what?
There's nothing in here.
Open the door.
Wait, she's back up?
How?
You got shot in the- wait, no, this is a different nurse.
Where did you come from?
All right, I don't know how we got this code, but like we're here.
All right.
Oh, they feed me garbage and rot in me.
Crawling with maggots, thick with sinew.
They make me bite down.
The juice is red and yellow.
Hit the back of my throat.
I choke and I gag.
And I vomit.
Until my throat is sore.
An aching, throbbing tube of flesh.
I push it all out, but I can still taste it.
Oh my god, that's fucking gross.
Oh my god.
That's a problem.
I don't think this is health code.
Guys, I think there's a health code violation here.
Oh no.
Well, I wish I could see what that is.
I wish I could see that.
This can't be right.
This has to be a health code violation.
Hello?
I go downstairs.
Or maybe upstairs?
Oh, there's the painting.
Wait, where do I go now?
Like I'm stuck.
Is this where I was before?
Oh, this is not where I was before.
Opens map unexplored.
I'm like, whoa, I definitely have never been here.
Whoops.
Hello?
Oh, there you are.
Back here.
What's your Silent Hill?
What does your Silent Hill look like, little lady?
Must be better than what the fuck I'm doing.
Can I go to your Silent Hill?
Your Silent Hill might be a lot better than what I'm going through right now.
Can I visit?
Hello?
Oh, there you are.
I see her.
Can she open the door?
But we'll find out.
Yep, she can.
There we go.
I'm just gonna use bullets.
It's just easier.
Really, it's just easier against them.
I feel like...
I've tried to like hit them with my pipe, but like you shouldn't hit women with your pipe and like...
And like it just takes too long.
If I'm gonna hit... if I'm gonna put her out of her misery...
It's easier to just use the pistol.
Shoot her ass.
It's easier also because it's headshots, too.
There we go.
It does not help that they flinch.
They really won't.
It does not help at all.
Oh my god.
It's actually pretty...
It's harder to hit, but it saves a lot of time.
Patient transferred for observation.
Malnourished.
Shallow breathing.
Avoids eye contact.
Oh, wait, that's me!
Wait, that's not...
Baby, that's not good.
Patient two refuses solid food.
Uh, forced feed.
Okay, that's not me.
Never mind.
I don't want to be this person.
Something is very wrong.
What's wrong with this guy?
Guys, I... not me anymore.
Not me.
Maybe I should start hitting them with my pipe to save ammo, but like, it just takes so long!
Usually, it's like three shots.
I feel like three shots is just faster.
I don't know.
Oh, come on.
Are you...
Come on!
Where are all these puzzles?
Okay.
I don't know where that would go.
I don't think... I don't think you guys are gonna give me another one.
These are not even good puzzles.
Don't lie.
These aren't even good puzzles.
It's...
A combination lock is not a good puzzle.
I said it.
I fucking said it.
Wait, where do I go?
This way?
If I could, I fucking would break the window.
If I...
If I could, I would fucking... I'll break that window right there.
Right there and now.
I'll do it.
I'll fucking...
Okay, I need to use the bathroom.
I'll be right back, guys.
Back.
I'm back in my own personal Silent Hill.
All right.
Like, where do I go?
Oh my god, where do I even go at this point?
Where am I?
All right.
Taking my time.
Fucking course I'm taking my time, guys.
I'm in Silent Hill.
Like, what do you want from me?
I'm trapped in this fucking hellhole.
I don't... I don't even know the combination.
Oh my god.
What is it?
Do I have the item that tells me?
Okay, no, that's just... that's just my...
That's just my... those are just my happy pills.
My happy pills and my...
My happy syringe that's not shared.
These needles definitely look like it was never shared at all.
Oh my god.
Like, what do I do?
Where am I?
It looks so clean, guys.
I like... like, I have to go somewhere else, but I don't even know where to go anymore.
I feel like I'm trapped here.
Been here?
Yeah, I have.
Look at the wall.
Which wall?
Do I have to go back?
Double tap.
Triple tap.
There's a wall?
We'll never know.
Oh, hey.
Oh, shit.
That's what you meant.
Break the window, Doki!
I was like, bro, if I could, I would.
Oh, there's the window.
There's...
There's the window, okay.
We have the inner working.
Oh, so that's what you meant.
That's what you meant by break the window.
It's like, of course, I'm trying.
I don't know what you guys want from me.
If there was a window, I would break it.
I see as I stood next to a window, I...
Guys, don't you guys know birds can't see windows?
Can you really blame me?
Birds can't see windows.
I mean, I have one of it.
Is that not it?
Is there another thing?
Dr. Andrews, we delivered the radiographs you requested.
However, it looks like the file was incomplete as one of the pictures was nowhere to be found.
We will send something as soon as we locate it.
Oh, wait, I have it.
I literally have the picture right here.
And I wish I could see it.
Okay.
There we go.
That's one of them.
And what are... moldy radiation?
How do I clean it?
I have to clean this fucker?
Turn on the sink, right?
Oh, what happened to the faucet?
I don't even turn it on.
I don't even have a faucet.
Oh my gosh, my life's a mess.
Oh my... where the plumbing at?
What happened to the plumbing?
Okay, we gotta go to the first...
What is it?
We have the...
God, how do you clean mold?
Like at that point just fucking throw it away.
I have the one first floor inner ward key.
Okay.
Off we go.
Back to hell, I guess.
Why can't I just take her pipe?
I should be legally allowed to take that pipe away from her hands.
Like, why am I letting them hold the pipe?
I should be legally allowed to take it away from her.
She's a danger to society.
Why do you need two pipes?
Like, I don't know, dual wield that shit.
Like...
I'm fucking dual wield.
All right, here we go.
Back at it again.
God, this game...
Apparently, this isn't even the long part.
I think that's like the worst part.
This is like not even the...
Not even the longest level.
I feel like 80 years have passed since I've been in Silent Hill.
Oh, there's one more nurse here.
Where is she?
Oh, there she is.
Slowly walking over.
Is that it?
There we go.
All right.
Back at it.
Where did that nurse come from?
I actually don't know where that nurse came from.
All right, down I go to the first floor.
Oh, fuck, okay.
Fuck.
No, but why?
Okay, it's fine.
It wasn't filled up.
Oh my god.
Oh, she came from the supply closet?
God damn it.
I fucking...
Oh.
All right, I didn't realize she opened the supply closet.
It's self-defense.
She came at me with a pipe.
What do I do?
Just grab her?
She literally... she started it.
She started it.
She piped first.
Oh, it was open.
Oh, she came from that area.
Like this area?
Oh, nice.
Fucking thank god the ammo I wasted on this bitch.
I can say it.
She was.
I can say it because I'm a bitch too.
Bitches recognize bitches.
I have recognized a fellow bitch when I see one.
So true.
So, so fucking true.
I have the pass.
I have.
All right.
Let's see.
Inner ward.
Back at it again.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
This was never open before.
I've been here for so long.
I was like, wait a minute.
I don't remember this door being open.
So I like took a second glance.
I was like, what?
Why was this open?
What the fuck?
You fucking...
Oh my god, Q.
I thought, I thought she opened it.
That's why I didn't care.
That's fine.
At least she was there.
That's nothing.
What do you mean 18?
Okay, like what do you mean?
That's nothing.
What do you mean?
There's nothing there, Chase.
I don't know what you mean.
Oh my god, I'm running out of ammo because of the nurses.
I hope I'll find more.
Maybe I shouldn't keep shooting them.
I can't help it.
There's another one?
Oh shit, I was not... oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
You okay there?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
You know what?
I don't...
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, she got the second wind.
I don't know.
I felt like she was having a good time.
Like, I don't know.
Like, look at her go.
I thought she was grooving.
I didn't want to bother her.
I felt bad.
Like, I thought she was just, you know, punking it out.
I just felt bad.
She was just vibing, you know?
It looked like she was vibing.
She was having a good time.
So I was like, well, I shouldn't...
I feel like I shouldn't bother her.
All right, I'm gonna shoot less this time because like...
I'm just gonna pipe the nurses at this point.
Like, I'm wasting a lot.
Which one do I fight first?
I guess this one.
Okay, that was... I wasted bullets there, but that was awkward.
All right, I'll do one headshot and then we're gonna pipe.
Okay, nice.
How long does it take though?
Like, how long?
Pipe.
Oh, wait!
Wait a minute!
I should have... wait!
Oh my god, I wasted so much ammo.
That's awkward, I...
I should have done that first.
Pipe!
What?
She can just grab me like that?
Oh my god, this lady is much more scarier than all the other ladies.
What the fuck?
She can resist the pipe?
Okay, I... I was not ready for the grab.
I...
I was not ready for her to fight back.
This nurse is not like the other nurses.
She's not like the other girls.
She actually grabbed my pipe.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, take me out on a date first if you want to grab my pipe.
Whoa, that's so forward of her.
I was not expecting that.
Oh, do I clean it with this?
No.
I need to find something here.
Yo, she was moving a bit too fast, lady.
He got out of the pool and made a break for the garden, cutting himself wide open in the process.
Thank god I was still here.
He was completely manic, screaming, had the orderlies hold him down.
Barely managed to stitch him up.
He's back into his room now.
Sedated.
What the fuck is going on?
What the fuck is going on here?
I opened this door.
I could just leave right now.
Oh.
There's a guy out there.
Wait, I could just leave right now.
I didn't think that would work.
So, oh my god.
I just left.
I saw a guy over there and I got scared.
Oh my god, guys, I could.
I can't believe it.
I actually could just leave.
Do I have to be closer if I'm going to do this?
He's just too far.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
He's...
And he's dead.
Alright, nice.
I wasn't ready to, like, actually leave.
I thought it was a joke.
You know how, like, you're like, I want to leave already!
I want to leave!
And then they open the door and you're just like, wait.
Get over here.
Get your ass over here.
What the fuck?
You're so fast.
Get your ass over here.
That's right, you're not getting up.
Getting up privileges, we're gone.
There we go.
I'm so like a cat.
It was like, James was like, wait, I actually want to see.
I did not expect him to just let me leave.
Like, I said that as a joke.
Bro, like, the crawlers, like, do nothing.
They...
Okay.
Okay!
Alright, I appreciate their letting me, like, look at her for a bit.
Thanks for letting me look at you.
Blackfire, thank you for the 10 gifted ships.
Thank you.
Thanks for letting me look at you.
Oh my god.
That freaked me out.
Oh my god, thank you.
I really appreciate the wind-up.
Is there anything in here?
Nice, more ammo.
I need ammo so badly.
Something there.
Oh yeah, it told me to go to the pool.
They can bite my ankles?
They haven't done jack shit.
They're weak as fuck.
Fuck!
Okay.
Oh my god, I thought I killed all of you.
I thought you were all gone.
I thought you were all fucking dead.
I didn't even need to be here.
I just wanted to be here just for the sake of it.
Like, I didn't even need to be over here in the corner.
You can stay there forever.
What?
They're back up?
You stay there.
I don't want to waste my ammo on you.
You don't matter.
You're just a waste of ammo at this point.
Can I touch the water?
What if I should?
I feel like there's brain-eating bacteria living down there.
Like, at this point.
Yeah, I've done nothing.
God damn it.
Yeah, I feel like...
I don't know.
I just feel like there's...
Yeah, I can't.
Oh, thank god.
I can't.
Good.
I don't need one to anyway.
I don't want to touch that.
This feels way too fucking gross.
Okay.
Alright, thank god.
He was like, MY FRIEND!
MY FRIEND WAS MY BEST FRIEND!
That's fucking right and I'll do it again.
Now you can join your best friend in hell.
Alright, nice.
More ammo.
We've been best friends for 20 years.
Another guy here?
Is he hidden like here?
Like, what?
What am I listening to?
Oh shit, USB cord.
Oh, I made a...
Oh shit, thank god.
I got my USB cord.
I got it.
Let's see.
Finally, I can charge my phone, guys.
Alright, nice.
Alright, I got double tap in.
I swear, that other nurse was fucking insane.
That other nurse was actually crazy.
I don't know how she could do that.
Did I come here already?
I don't remember.
My god, I've lost track of all the places I've been.
Y'all look the same to me.
Y'all look the same.
I don't know.
This case bears a disturbing similarity to a simulation situation that took place in a facility a few years back.
The patient was admitted on a court order, but with the consent of the...
Oh wait, I've never read this before.
His condition appeared to be improving for the first few weeks.
The administered medications paired with individual sessions of a psychologist and art therapy elevated his evolution and social withdrawal.
There was no reason for concern.
He didn't even know anything was wrong until the night guard reported when his key was missing.
When they found him, it was already too late.
Too late for what?
You think he's okay?
Oh hey, that's the password.
Hey guys, we found it.
Guys, I told you eventually we found it.
I didn't cheat.
We just got there faster.
See, we found the password, guys.
Not cheating if we eventually get there.
We just got there faster.
Alright, another door unlocked.
Oh my god, okay.
Where does this door go to?
Where am I?
Where the fuck am I?
Okay, back here.
Alright.
Day room.
That's where I killed that other nurse and that guy.
Alright, and that nurse too.
Oh, those are some nice shoes, man.
Oh my god, I did so many kills.
Alright.
Over here.
Guys, how much of the hospital do I have left?
Wait, is this not the med- Oh, I got combined!
Okay, alright.
My brain is going overtime right now.
This...
Uh...
Fuck, okay.
Key items.
E with this.
I'm learning.
I don't need no back seating.
Uh...
Thank you, thank you.
What a sad life.
And they deserve it.
No one can be hotter than James.
If they're hotter than me...
They're gonna die by the pipe.
Alright.
And then I can use it to charge my iPhone later.
Maintenance key?
Oh, it's a pool!
It's a pool key.
Are they all back?
No way.
Are you serious?
No, it's just him.
Wait, where did he go?
Yeah, it's just him.
He just had a second life in him.
For some fucking reason.
Okay, yeah.
Get back.
Get out of here.
Alright.
How the fuck did he came back alive?
All the others stayed dead.
What makes you not special?
You thought you were the main protagonist.
But you were made just to die by my hands.
Alright.
Purpose fulfilled.
Time to drain the water.
What's in here?
Can I just jump?
Jump, James.
We're gonna get fall damage?
Oh my god, I don't trust you.
I don't trust you.
Oh my god.
I don't know.
Why are they just in the pool?
Why are they just there?
They get back up, aren't they?
They just get up.
Fucking knew it.
I knew it.
There's no way you stay dead.
Oh, I knew it.
Where are you?
Get back here.
That's right.
Oh, you thought you could get away?
Your life is meaningless.
Get out.
Get out of my head.
There we go.
I knew one of them was pretending.
Alright.
Now where am I?
Okay, I'm in the shower room.
Have I been here?
I have.
This is where I killed his best friend.
Okay, I have one of them now.
What do I do?
I can't.
I'm gonna go crazy.
Oh, okay.
I haven't gone this way, the other way yet.
Okay, I'm gonna put the...
Actually, I'm gonna go this way.
Then...
It's the other way.
Yeah, I didn't go the first wing.
This way.
Okay.
I didn't go this way yet.
Okay, here we go.
Okay.
Hello?
Oh, this is the... Oh, wait.
This is the drain.
Hello?
Thank fucking god.
Alright, ma'am.
I feel like you're gonna put me in a scenario where...
Where there's gonna be, like, three of these women about to get me.
I can feel it.
I feel that there's gonna be 300 of these.
I...
I put three women and I don't know what to do with three women.
That's too, too many women.
I have two hands.
I...
It's three too many.
Please don't make...
Don't put... Give me three.
I don't know what to do.
Like, I don't even know what to do with one.
Like...
God, give me two hands.
Oh...
What am I gonna do here?
Is there...
There's a woman.
I know there is.
I know you're here.
Oh, nice.
Mold remover.
Oh, there you are.
Okay.
I can get two stabs in in another way when she's running.
Yeah.
I'm so sorry.
Oh, fuck.
God, she's different.
She's so different.
Holy shit, she's different.
I'm just gonna shoot her in the head.
No, she took out...
Okay, that's fine.
She's so different.
It's in the walls deep inside the mold remover.
It gets rid of it for a while, but then the thing reappears in the exact same spot.
We need to get in there, break it all down.
We have to and root it out.
That's an elite.
That's a fucking elite nurse right there.
Oh, she's so different.
She's not like the other nurses.
She grabbed my pipe.
Oh, my God.
Whoa, Mom.
Mommy.
Oh, my God.
She's scary.
Those are scary nurses.
Whoa, she hit back.
I think she'll grab it.
Oh, my God.
Whoa.
Don't grab it.
Don't grab it, please.
No, I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Oh, my God.
Okay, we're fine.
No, she's not her.
She's not her.
Oh, she is her.
Oh, she is.
I'm sorry.
Oh, my God.
I'm so sorry.
I'm shooting her.
She's elite.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
She's also like her.
She's just like her, too.
Bro, when they hit back, like, what do I do?
I'm so used to them.
Like, I had, like, a system.
You don't understand, chat.
I had an entire system for them.
And then they just came in and, like, ruined it all.
Like, she ruined the system.
It made, like, whoa.
It, like, freaked me out.
Wasn't used to it.
I wasn't used to them just...
working back.
They adapted.
Okay, I got the cafeteria.
I got the mold remover.
So we have to go back to the x-ray room.
Where the fuck that was?
I'm losing track.
Where I've been.
No, I have a shotgun.
See?
I just refuse to use it.
Okay.
Yeah, I got it.
Guys, you don't understand.
The shotgun is for boss fights only.
It's for Silent Hill 2.5.
It's for...
You won't understand.
You won't...
Alright.
Oh, yeah, it's this way.
Cause I unlocked the gate, right?
From here.
It should be faster.
Where the fuck is...
Oh, there it is.
I was like, where the fuck is that goddamn gate I unlocked?
It should be here.
Okay.
And the x-ray room is here.
Yeah.
Guys, I don't know if you know this, but ammo transfer is over.
I'll have enough ammo for Silent Hill 3 remaster, guys.
You won't understand.
And when they transfer the ammo in Silent Hill 3, who's gonna be laughing then?
Heather's gonna get all my ammo.
Alright, here we go.
Wait, I never placed these guys here.
How the fuck did that get here?
Alright, let's see.
Yeah.
And then mold remover.
Oh nice, now it's back.
Put it over there before things get weird.
Okay, skull trauma.
Alright, we know where that is.
That's skull trauma right here.
And then this is...
Old fracture?
Guys, I don't know how to read this.
Okay.
How the fuck do I put these then?
Oh!
Oh god, I'm so stupid.
Wait, no, don't answer that.
Wait, I, fucking, oh my god.
Okay, there's lines.
There's...
Oh my god, there's rotation!
I can ro...
Guys, whoa.
Guys, did you know you can rotate this?
Did you?
Oh my god, I was gonna be like, why doesn't it fit?
Oh my god.
Guys, you can rotate pictures.
This changes everything.
This actually changes everything.
This makes so much more sense now.
Yeah, that goes here.
Okay, this should be here.
There we go.
437?
Is that 37?
The fuck is an F?
I can't tell.
Can't read doctor's handwriting.
Is that fancy F?
Okay, I was gonna say, like, 87.
Sorry, 43712.
Okay, we got it.
437...
I forgot you write 7s like that.
That's so weird.
Stop being so pretentious.
Write it the right way.
Okay, 43712.
4...
37...
12.
Nice.
The fancy F.
I was so confused.
I was like, why so fancy?
Last wristwatch must be here.
I don't like that there's a cutscene.
And the little girl's gonna be like, BOOM!
Like, what else would it be?
Okay,
nice, we got it.
We got the last...
Sorry, I just realized they're not watches.
I just...
I just realized they're patient bands.
I was like, whoa, there's so many wristwatches here.
They're...
I just realized they weren't supposed to be watches.
They're like, patient...
Mental patient bands.
Like watches, I don't know.
How do I get downstairs faster?
Oh, this way.
Double tap.
Oh my god, okay.
Okay, save.
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
Down we go.
And then down we go again.
And then...
Down we're going.
And then where?
Now where?
Cause now I'm lost again.
Oh, here.
Okay.
Here we go.
I realized I went the wrong way, but that's okay.
I don't care anymore.
I just want to save in the other area.
Here we go.
I'm going the longest way possible.
But that's okay.
I just wanted to be here.
I went too down.
Guys, trust the process.
It was all intentional.
I just wanted to be over here.
Give me a second.
The worst thing about...
I need to check my volume sometimes.
When I blow my nose, or when I cough too hard, I mute myself.
But when I mute myself, the GoXLR sometimes doesn't go all the way back up.
So it lowers my...
It lowers the volume sometimes.
So I have to make sure I don't accidentally lower it all the way down.
So yeah.
It's very annoying sometimes.
Because I have it at default 90.
But sometimes when I mute it too much, it goes to 86.
And I'm like, that's not right.
That's not right.
Okay, the director's office.
Why can't I open the door from here?
Wait, did I not unlock it?
I'm so dumb.
I didn't unlock it.
I...
No, it actually matters!
It actually lowers you so much!
It's true!
Okay, back here.
Okay, now I should unlock this.
Can you not?
Oh my god, I can't believe I forgot to unlock this part.
Actually, I can't believe it.
Oh, I can actually.
Alright.
We got the three hands now.
Alright, there you go.
Am I supposed to...
Oh my god, are you serious?
Are you fucking...
Are you...
Do I have to move you correctly?
Oh, I don't know!
There's a puzzle to this?
Oh my god, okay, let me...
Let me read.
Alright.
Okay.
The numbers?
They like, draw on top of the numbers.
437!
S1!
Thank you for the superchat!
Thank you for 10 gift ships!
Thank you, thank you!
I assume, like, it has something to do with these.
The numbers, what do they mean?
What do the numbers mean?
Oh, there you go.
98.
We did it!
Oh my god, we're so smart.
We did it.
Oh my god.
I fucking knew it.
Oh my god, I'm so smart.
I knew that was the answer all along.
Oh shit.
Fuck it, whatever.
I have like, 300 gigabytes left.
Not even gigabytes, what is it?
I have 900 gigabytes left of memory.
It's alright.
What's one more to go?
Alright, the safe button.
Oh?
Okay.
Oh wait, this is easy.
Oh, okay.
It's just pictures.
Okay, I can't fuck that up.
I literally can't fuck this up.
Okay, I can.
I actually...
Okay, alright.
That's a little embarrassing.
I actually can fuck this up.
I...
Okay, wait.
Yeah, no.
This is correct.
I actually could.
Who would've thought?
There we go.
I did it!
Okay.
Fuck!
Okay, I'm gonna screenshot this.
Okay.
Oh my god, can I not screenshot this?
What is it?
No, it's a black screen!
You're not allowed to illegally screenshot this game!
I'm not gonna remember this!
Okay.
I can't illegally screenshot this game.
It gives me a black screen like in Netflix.
Oh, it's on my map?
Oh, thank god.
Oh my god, thank fucking god.
Thank god it's on my map.
Use my phone!
No, I can't!
I need my phone for VTubing!
Okay.
Wait, what?
Did he ever tell me the numbers?
Did he ever tell me what the...
Okay, let me...
Is there any numbers here?
Did he ever...
Oh, there it is.
Okay, no, that's not it.
Oh my god, did he...
This is the wrist.
Must be the wrist, right?
Okay.
924571 924571, okay.
9245 Oh my god, where's my map?
Where's my fucking map?
9...
Okay, moon H.
Moon...
Oh shit.
We gotta reset this.
Okay.
Moon H.
92 Mel Boob Okay, Mel Boob.
Mel Boob Okay, what's the next one?
92451 924571 246 2467 2467 Evil woman And then smash bros.
Okay, we got that.
Evil woman, smash bros.
Alright.
Evil woman Smash bros.
What?
That's literally it!
92451 92468 Oh my god, it's not moon, it's a triangle!
I can't count!
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
Oh my god, sorry.
That fucking... what was it called?
The triangle...
Uh...
Okay.
Illuminati H.
Mel Boob.
Mel Boob Evil woman, smash bros.
There we go.
It works!
I actually memorized it by then.
Okay, rooftop.
Alright, there we go.
We did it.
We fucking figured it out.
It's how...
It's how our principles...
Our code...
Of a lifetime.
It's the women's side with Horns on it!
So it's like evil!
Cause there's horns on the women's side.
Alright, where the fuck is rooftop?
If it works, it works, you know?
How do I get to the fucking rooftop?
That's the basement.
That's the third floor.
Laura?
Like...
Huh?
I'm looking at all these maps.
Is that where the...
Laura is?
Is it where Laura is?
Can't tell.
There's so many.
Can't tell anymore.
I'm gonna cry.
I have so many staircases.
Which one?
The top left or the bottom right?
There's so many staircases.
There's like fucking arrows everywhere!
Top left or bottom right?
There's two staircases.
Which one do I go?
Top left?
Is it top left staircase?
I can't go up cause there's two areas.
Top?
Okay, top left, okay.
Top left.
Oh my god, here we go.
Backtracking yet again.
Top left.
Right.
Okay, here we go.
There's just too many staircases, guys.
There's too many.
Too many.
There's just way too many staircases.
Hello?
Wait, that doesn't unlock this door.
I still go up?
Guys, you fucking liars.
There's an...
What do you mean up again?
I'm...
Oh, there's another one right here.
There's another...
I forgot about this staircase.
Oh my god, I forgot this one existed.
There's so many stairs.
I am losing myself in the staircase.
I've lost myself.
Oh my god, now it's raining?
How much more depressed can you be?
James, this is why you need to take your meds, James.
Oh my god, when it rains, it means you're extra depressed.
Wait, can I...
Okay, I can't go over there.
I have to go here.
This is all in your head, James.
This is all in your head.
You caused this.
Okay.
Can't go there yet though.
I'm pretty sure.
What's the plan?
Survive.
There's no plan.
I'm just trying to make it in this big world.
How do I grab the ammo that's over there?
Oh.
Oh, that's how.
I didn't see the staircase.
Okay, nice.
More shotgun ammo I can hoard.
Okay.
Rain.
Stared out the window all day.
Peaceful here, nothing to do.
Still not allowed to go outside.
Still raining.
Talked to the doctor a little.
Would they have seen me if I didn't have a family to feed?
I know I'm pathetic and weak.
Not everyone can be strong.
Rain again.
The meds made me feel sick today.
If I'm only better when I'm drunk, then who am I anyway?
Oh, that's sad.
I'm not a fucking crazy murderer.
I don't know what you were like before the meds kicked in.
Like...
Okay, this way.
This way I go.
I go here.
Alright.
Okay.
Alright, I was just told it's gonna be posted tomorrow, not today.
Remember when I was like, oh, something might be posted today?
JK, it's tomorrow.
JK.
Wait, that's it?
That wasn't just it.
JK.
It wasn't it.
That wasn't just it.
Oh my god.
Alright.
That's not it.
I'm sorry.
Don't get mad at me.
Where am I?
Oh, I'm on the side Laura was at.
I'm on Laura's side.
Laura's here.
Nice.
More... more... very, very clean and safe syringes right here.
Feels so clean and safe.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry, Pyramid Head.
You'll get it tomorrow.
Pyramid Head, I'm sorry.
The announcement will be tomorrow instead.
I'm so sorry.
I didn't mean it.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Ooh, whoa.
Lucky Noji, he hits you with his big knife and you lost a chunk of your health.
Whoa, that's not me.
What's this?
Oh.
Lore!
Hello?
Is Laura here?
Laura?
Hey, Laura.
Hey.
So, I'm gonna go... where are you?
Yeah, how do I know her?
Oh, Eddie.
Okay, I forgot Eddie told me.
Whoa, that's rude.
He's human too, I think.
Whoa, whoa.
I'm not like that.
I'm on medication.
Well, like I was, but like...
Like, I'm better now, I swear.
Oh shit, and you lived?
How did my wife die and you live?
Laura, no!
Wait, if she is alive, that means my wife is alive too?
I knew it!
I knew that funeral was not real.
I knew she faked it.
If she's alive, that means my wife's alive too.
She explains everything.
What?
You hid it?
Wait, that seems like a dangerous door, Laura.
Why did you hide in here?
I don't know, Laura.
Are you fucking with me?
Are you gaslighting me, Laura?
Whoa.
It feels like she's gaslighting me right now.
Oh my God, just like my wife.
Did she teach you that?
I'm a liar, right?
Can you open it?
Huh?
Do ya?
Laura, open this door right now.
What's the magic word?
Laura.
Nope, that's not it.
I guess I won't open it.
Laura, open the fucking door, you fucking...
Oh, you're a child, I can't see it.
She's gonna grow up to be a bitch too, I recognize it.
I can see it.
That was little me.
I know I'm a bitch.
I can recognize.
Real recognize, real.
I recognize.
Whoa.
Oh, is this a boss fight?
Guys, I knew my shotgun...
Whoa!
My God.
Okay.
Alright, I assume I shoot this, right?
Like, I don't know where else to shoot.
I mean, fucking, did you see the mouth?
Oh, shit!
Don't... Fuck, okay.
He hit back, guys.
That's not fair.
He hits back.
You're not supposed to shoot back.
Where?
I'm supposed to reload my gun, but...
Fuck, okay.
Bro.
Oh my God, now he has two legs.
Oh my God, now he has two arms.
Oh my God.
Okay.
That's right.
This is what I would save the bullets for!
Oh, four arms!
You know what they say about four arms.
You know what they say.
Okay.
Oh, shit!
Is he dead?
He's not dead.
He was dead!
Little does she know, he was definitely not dead.
She doesn't even...
Oh my God, I'm so sorry.
Oh my God.
I'm doing so much healing.
Are you dead?
Oh my God, that's so much...
That was all my fucking heals.
And my shotgun bullet.
Wait, that was so easy.
What the fuck?
It's purpose has been fulfilled.
Oh, shit!
I'm sorry!
I didn't mean to call her easy!
I didn't...
I didn't mean it!
She was...
She was the best thing in my life.
I'm so sorry.
Oh no, I don't have shotgun ammo for him.
Are you a pyramid head?
I thought he was the only boss I had to fight.
Mary?
I knew the hospital people lied.
I knew you survived.
I don't know why.
I knew they buried the wrong body.
I should've...
I knew I should've checked the coffin before they buried you.
It was weird that they closed the coffin so that I couldn't see you during the funeral.
I fucking knew it.
Not taking those meds are finally paying off.
Oh no, am I in the other world?
Where am I?
Oh, that's a wheelchair in the middle.
Did a miracle happen?
Why is there a wheelchair in the middle?
Did somebody learn how to walk?
Maybe somebody learned how to walk, guys.
You don't...
You don't know that.
Hello?
There's save points?
Oh, thank God.
Oh, thank God there's a save point.
There's a scarier version of the fucking hospital!
How?!
Is this not scary enough?!
How do you make a scarier version?!
I think saving those shotgun bullets was a good idea.
Is it usually that... Was it supposed to be that easy or did I just luck out?
Or was just... No, it's not luck and skill.
Or was I just that good?
Wait, do I go...
Oh, was there a note in the... Was there a note there?
Oh, there was?
Okay, I'll go back.
Sorry, we'll go to this.
We'll come back later.
Oh, he's like a bullet sponge?
Oh, nice.
I'm just a gamer.
I told you guys!
Hoarding is good!
Guys, don't listen to the other people.
Hoarding is good.
I didn't realize there was a note.
I thought it was just a miracle.
Initial symptoms.
Hyper focus.
They can be fixed.
Stop at nothing.
I told you.
I'm fixable.
Told you guys.
You can fix me.
I can fix him.
I knew it.
Alright, here we go.
Which way is it?
Which way?
Oh, this is the way.
Oh my god, bro.
Oh, this is the cafeteria area.
Without the cafeteria.
Oh my god.
Okay.
What's this?
Hey guys, we could skip all of this right now.
Imagine.
Imagine if I was like, alright guys, let's just make this quick, guys.
Let's just make this quick, everybody.
Alright, back to my hoarding.
Back to my hoarding.
Are the nurses stronger in this area too?
In the other world?
Oh,
they look stronger.
Wait, do they have less clothes?
Wait, they have knives?!
That's cheating!
Oh, they are stronger!
Fuck!
Okay.
What happened to my light?
Wait, my light's gone.
Wait, she broke my light!
She shaked the knife- the light out of my...
She shaked the- my flashlight!
Where's my flashlight?
Oh, I turned it off.
JK.
Sorry, I turned it off out of fear.
She shanked me so hard, I actually turned my flashlight off.
I think it's understandable.
It's understandable.
Okay, I forgot about those fuckers.
Alright, okay.
I don't know, man.
I don't...
My god, I knew it.
I baited her.
Oh, did you see that bait, though?
I knew it.
I knew she wanted to grab this pipe.
No, no, no.
Not taking me out on a date first.
Crawl time.
Alright, meds.
And then...
Nice, more shotgun.
Thank god.
More hoarding.
Oh, I need this for Pyramid Head when he fucking gets me.
When he comes down there and fucking gets me.
Oh my god, okay.
Alright, I can't go this way.
This way is god too.
I don't know.
There's too many choices.
Oh, where's Laura?
Laura, where are you, you fucking child?
Who did this?
Who did this, Laura?
This is your fault.
Oh.
Okay.
Wow, we danced, arms flailing, our bodies in perfect synchrony.
And the music played, but in any dance, there comes a time.
One must take the lead, and the music got louder and louder.
Pounding, piercing, and then silence.
The fuck kind of wrote this?
Oh, they're all chained up.
Is he okay?
Oh.
What's this?
Is that an instrument of force?
Oh, okay, I got another one.
Nice.
Is that it?
Oh, and then I add an eye.
I have to give him an eye.
Hello.
Okay.
Oh.
I hear you.
Hello?
I know you're there.
Oh, there she is.
Give this nurse a knife.
Maybe I'll do one more headshot.
Yeah, that's right!
Fucking projectile bitch!
Oh, shit!
What the fuck?
Oh, it's this guy!
Where did he come from?
I didn't realize it was the spiky guy.
It's just like, I forgot we're in this world.
Spiky guys exist in this world.
They get extra kinky.
Okay.
Get down.
Alright.
Oh, thank God.
He predicted your prediction!
I forgot they existed!
What the fuck?
Like, why are you- Stop!
Stop running!
I see you!
She's like, I don't think she saw me.
I saw him to book it.
Like, she just walked away.
It was like, do you think- Oh, I think that was a fluke.
I don't think she saw me.
I don't- Maybe she thought it was the wind.
Okay.
Down.
Okay, I guess we go downstairs.
There's nothing back here.
Oh wait, no.
Ha!
You thought I didn't see the cracked wall, did you?
That's right, I'm gaming now.
I'm actually gaming.
I see everything.
Alright.
Down the creepy hole we go.
When there's a hole, there's a gold.
Here I go.
Oh, why is this so far?
It's like right here.
Like, I don't know what you expected.
Alright.
These guys aren't as scary.
They're just there.
They just- They're just standing there.
It's when they pop out, but like...
It doesn't help that they just stand there.
They just- They're just there.
What?
Where did I go?
Like, where am I now?
My god.
Where am I?
Oh, there's the other nurse.
Oh, it's the easy one.
Oh shit, the double tap!
It's still pretty easy though.
Ah, fuck off!
No!
Triple tap?!
I'm sorry, you're not- I'm- What?!
I gave up.
I don't want to dodge anymore.
It's too much work.
It is just too much work.
Okay.
Oh, the triple!
Okay, they do triples now.
Okay.
That's good to know.
That's...
Good...
TO KNOW!
OH SHIT!
What?
Where did you come from?
What the- No, not you!
I'm not- I FUCKED UP!
I HIT THE THIRD GUY!
My fucking pipe just auto-aced into that.
My pipe literally just auto-aced that.
Like, I didn't even know where this guy came from.
That's actually a party.
Oh my god.
That was funny.
That was actually- It actually came out of a fucking noob.
He's just like, Hey, I don't wanna- Hey, what's going on guys?
Why wasn't I invited?
My pipe actually just aim-assisted that whole- Holy fuck.
I did not see him, that's for sure.
I definitely did not see that guy.
Okay...
This way...
Where's this go?
Oh, time to stick my hand into the creepy hole!
Okay...
Hello?
Did I go everywhere?
Wait...
Heard something.
Definitely heard something.
That's not supposed to be here.
Okay...
I feel like there's something here that shouldn't be here.
Hello?
Oh, there you are.
Hello there.
Okay...
Let me go check this out.
Go up before you come back.
Alright, nice.
She needed her privacy, clearly.
She have anything?
Oh, nice shotgun.
Nice.
Oh, I need to make sure I have enough ammo later.
I'm running out of ammo.
She wasn't- Guys!
Guys, she wasn't done with the fucking bathroom!
I didn't want to be rude!
Okay...
I think I- Did I go to the- Yeah, I did.
I go to the medical area already.
It was like a little cubby hole here.
Right?
No, there wasn't.
I'm so- I'm so fucking confused now.
I thought there was like a little area for you to go under.
Did I explore everything?
I can't tell.
Everything blends in for me.
The underworld is so same-y that I can't tell anymore.
Everything looks the same.
It's just all fucking mold and brown.
It's just mold everywhere.
Is it here?
I go to the surgical chair, right?
Okay.
Okay, it's this way.
I just went backwards.
Okay, whoops.
Everything just- I'm just so confused now.
I'm way too confused.
Alright, poke.
Poke, give me your eye.
Nice, I got the key.
Alright, now we can cheat.
No, I'm joking.
I'll do- Guys, I would never.
Guys, I would never.
I would never, guys.
I would never cheat.
But all I'm saying, I got the key though.
I do have the key.
I do have it.
Alright, I'm gonna call it here.
I'm gonna- I'm sorry.
I also have another stream.
I have a member stream tonight.
And I have the convention.
And I have a panel tonight at Vietnam.
So I don't wanna- I don't wanna fuck up my voice, guys.
I would actually play longer.
But like, I overbooked myself hella hard today.
I actually- I like overbooked myself.
I have dance lesson in the morning.
I have today's stream.
I have a member stream later.
And then I have a convention at 12 midnight.
And then I have my meet and greet.
I have a panel and a meet and greet.
And then, tomorrow, I have Payday 3 sponsor.
I have Payday 3 sponsor tomorrow.
And also dance lessons again.
So that's why.
I would actually play longer today.
But if I didn't overbook myself so hard today and tomorrow...
I fucked up a little bit.
Anyway, I'm gonna swap- I'm gonna swap over.
I did a little bit of super chat reading.
Because there's not a lot of super chats today to get through.
So I think I can do it.
I think it's possible.
Let me- Where are you guys?
Where's my chat?
There we go.
Yeah, I fucked up.
I overscheduled myself hard.
I overscheduled myself.
I'm sorry.
I couldn't help it.
It was like, do you want to do it with a sponsor?
And I'm like, sure.
And then we got the other sponsor at the same time.
And it was like, do you guys want to do it?
Sure.
And I was like, oh shit, my schedule's already decided.
Oh, well.
What's the worst that could happen?
By the way, Doki, you also have a convention today.
And I was like, oh, that's all right.
That should be fine.
Standard, welcome to the Domino Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Don't worry.
We'll eventually beat Silent Hill 2 one day.
Maybe.
We'll never...
That'd be so fucked.
We'd never start another series because we're still stuck in Silent Hill 2 purgatory.
We're still stuck in this purgatory.
But I'm getting more used to it.
I am getting more used to Silent Hill 2.
To the point where it's not as scary as it was when I first started.
When I first started, I was freaking the fuck out.
But now, I'm a lot better.
Now, I'm not as good, but I'm a bit better than what I was before.
It didn't help when I was stuck.
I felt like I was stuck in my own Silent Hill.
Where every fucking 5-10 minutes, it would be like...
And I'm like, please, I'm playing a horror game.
Stop.
I'm fucking playing a horror game.
Why do you do this to me?
PA system.
Alright.
Alright, what was that?
Okay.
Wait, oh my gosh.
I forgot to put super chat.
Oh, wait.
No, wait.
That's story time.
Where the fuck is my...
Guys, no, no.
It's not story time.
It's...
Oh my god.
Did I...
Accidentally overwrite...
No, it's this one.
There we go.
Donation reading time.
Alright.
Buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh.
Where was I?
Micah, LostCore, MediCat, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Paladin Knight, thank you for the super chat.
You could move the members stream the next week.
The dragons would not mind.
It prevents you from destroying your voice.
That's Paladin Knight.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Now I feel bad.
Because you guys were waiting.
Because I'm trying to keep the routine of every other week...
For members.
Especially because you guys pay a lot to be in the members.
Like every month.
And it's alright.
I might not do a very long stream though for tonight.
For members.
So I might not do a very long stream though.
But I still want to do a member stream.
I'll try to make it up for another member stream next week.
To make it longer.
But it'll be like the same thing.
It'll be like the profile pictures.
But I'll still do a member stream.
It's just I won't be doing a very long one.
But I'll still do it.
I'll do another one to make up for the small member stream.
For next week and stuff.
Because you guys paid a lot to be in the member stream.
And I want to make it up for you guys.
But yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Artheus, thank you for the super chat.
Ddragon, yeah that's what you get for skipping that door code puzzle.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Why did you blame me?
You guys were the weak ones.
One of you guys cracked.
It's not my fault.
All it takes is one dragon to betray the others.
That's all it took.
Pixel, thank you for the very first super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hello Doki, I really enjoy watching your streams.
Thank you for making me smile and laugh with all your streams.
You're such a joy to watch.
Also, it's my birthday.
Thank you for the very first super chat, Pixel.
Thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Neo.
Yeah!
Also, is like John still here?
Have you...
John, what do you have to say for yourself?
John...
Oh, you are here.
John, what do you have to say for yourself for betraying the dragon kind?
What do you have to say, John?
Get him.
I like how everyone was like, weak!
Shame!
John was like, I said the correct combination as a joke.
John was just like, I didn't think she would pick me.
There are so many numbers in chat.
How was I supposed to know she would pick the right one?
Shame, John.
Shame!
Alright.
So...
We have...
Okay, the thing is, we have two versions of this one.
So, we have...
This one, which is...
Basically, it's gonna replace our other one that looks just like this.
But we have two versions of it because I didn't know which one to pick.
We have this one versus...
Alright, we have...
Oh my god.
Okay, this one versus...
This one.
Alright, guys.
Don't mind the eye...
Oh, wait.
Actually, I should fix the...
I should fix the eye color, too.
Whoops.
Give me a sec.
So...
I don't know which eye color to use, guys.
I need you guys to help me.
Alright.
Which one...
Oh, wait.
That's the same one.
I'm sorry.
That's the same.
Okay, just give me... Give us both the same...
No, no, guys.
No, they're different.
They're different.
Trust me.
There we go.
Now.
Okay, there we go.
Alright.
So...
We have a problem.
You see, I don't know if we want the black eyes or the green eyes.
They're not the same.
Okay, like, which one, guys?
Left or right?
It's not the same!
It's not.
Green eyes?
Okay, green eyes.
Alright, now...
Okay, we also have...
Oh my gosh, which one was it?
I know, like, they gave me both options.
But, like, I was very sure about both of them.
Except for...
Alright, and then, here's the other one.
This one, we're gonna be calling some emotes for this.
We're gonna be...
Letting you guys know right now.
Like, we're gonna be calling some...
This will be replacing another emote.
Alright.
Left or right?
The right side?
Alright, I see more right.
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, and then, finally...
Okay, yeah.
Actually, no, that's it.
That's it.
Those were your picks.
Everything else is just...
Black eyes.
Alright!
So!
The great calling!
The purge!
Pick an emote you wish to purge.
Pick an emote.
I'm uploading emotes now.
Pick an emote you wish to banish and replace.
For a newer, shinier, prettier, and sexier version.
The emote you use...
You put in shall be purged.
Alright.
Let's see.
Yeah.
Alright, let me double check if everything is okay.
Alright, did I choose the right one for this emote?
Alright, guys, I'm like slowly fucking trying to figure out my emote situation right now, so...
I don't know if I even uploaded the right one for these.
Let me double check.
Camcorder.
Yeah, is this the right one?
I can't tell.
I need to make sure I uploaded the right emote.
Alright.
Okay, I see some good options.
Okay, alright.
Alright.
Let me upload these now.
We're doing it live, so you guys can use them too.
You guys can use them while we're doing it live.
Let me make sure.
I need to make sure I actually upload the right version.
I feel like I think I uploaded the wrong version.
Did I?
I can't tell.
Is this 112?
I can't tell anymore.
Okay, sorry.
I'm a professional.
I'm just trying to make sure they're the right emotes.
Okay.
Alright.
I saw the one we're purging.
We're gonna...
We're gonna get rid of Grrr.
It has...
It has been spoken by the...
By the council of the dragons.
Say goodbye to Grrr.
Grrr shall leave us now.
Goodbye, Grrr.
Goodbye.
Your final Grrrs.
Get those final Grrrs in before it's gone forever.
Shit.
Alright.
Save and publish.
Goodbye, Grrr.
He's gone.
He's gone for now.
He'll just be known as the square.
He's gone forever.
Alright.
Now that he's gone.
Say goodbye.
Wait, did we want a green eyes?
We want a green eyes, right?
Say goodbye to the other version of this.
Say goodbye.
Say goodbye to this version.
To the old version.
Give your last final thoughts.
Monsters!
Say goodbye to him.
Alright.
Before we purge them.
In 3...
2...
1...
Goodbye!
See you later!
Where are my other emotes?
Alright.
And then the other ones, I'm not even going to give you a choice.
I'm just going to...
It's going to be a surprise when you find out which one gets purged next.
Because I still have one more to purge.
And this one is going to be a surprise.
So it's just going to disappear.
You won't even know who disappeared.
It's just...
It's just gone.
Alright.
Also because I realized last minute that we had doubles of it.
I was like, oh yeah!
This is a...
I forgot I had...
I forgot I had a double of this emote.
So...
So because of it...
Alright, where's...
Okay, where is it?
Okay.
Here we go.
It was black eyes.
Yeah.
Alright, here we go.
Oh my gosh, where did I...
Okay.
No, that's not it.
Wait, which one did I replace?
Oh, there we go.
Alright.
Let's see.
Which one was the double again?
Alright, here we go.
I'm ready.
I'm ready to purge the last one.
Because I realized we had doubles.
So I was like, oh shit.
Like, I'm gonna...
I gotta get rid of that.
I gotta...
Alright.
Goodbye.
Oh, who did we lose?
It's time to find out who we lost.
The things I'm doing are my own shit.
Who did we lose?
I wonder.
It's time to figure it.
It's there now.
It's there.
Yeah, we lost one of the sprays.
I realized we had two sprays.
Only one spray left.
There's only one spray left.
And now we have sweat.
Yeah, but that's not a double.
One is dad and the other one is me.
That's technically not a double.
How am I gonna spray RetroDoki now?
It's over.
It's gone.
Alright.
Alright, that was a great mighty purge.
Welcome to your new emotes.
Now you have new emotes, guys.
Congratulations now.
You have five new emotes, chat.
And now we're gonna have another great purge next...
Not next week.
Whenever the next batch of emotes are done, we're gonna have another great purge of old emotes or double emotes.
And we'll finally have a little bit more variety.
I realized my emotes don't have a lot of variety.
But soon, soon we'll have more variety.
It'll be...
It'll be more variety soon.
Anyway, guys.
I am gonna call it here.
I know I said I was gonna read superchats and then I just read two.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Anyway, guys.
The great purge sort of got in the way.
As always, everybody.
Say hi.
Give him a round to get that blood flowing.
And if you did that for me, head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.